oh dude i want to say this so i was on
instagram maybe
a month ago and this pretty hot chick
right
kept text like not direct message
because i'm not i don't follow her
but it's like she was messaging me hey
does theo respond to his um
messages direct messages and i didn't
respond
but she's pretty hot i looked at her
[ __ ] thing and she keeps
asking me like how do i get ahold of
theo i really need to get a hold of him
with fans look at your eyes what are you
doing with your eyes
nothing that's how i looked that's what
i'm saying yeah yeah
i'm just saying like you know i mean now
i can see
like you mean very attractive women
trying to claw into your [ __ ] really
well how does she not just look me up
and find me then and say hey you know
but
but do you get a lot of like those
messages are you getting you don't want
to talk about this
no no i'm fine talking about it yeah
yeah what do i get i get
just not respond to them or no some i
respond to some i don't you know it's
definitely riskier these days
yeah after it's like you know you just
get really scared about somebody sharing
like personal communication
you know somebody recording your screen
even if it's just like hey what's up or
anything you know like
can i get your number this or that you
get scared of uh
i get scared of people like sharing that
or like screen grabbing it and like um
i don't know it just feels like uh
you know people are gonna use it to mess
with you i mean even after what happened
with dalia like
a lot of the stuff that got shared about
him a lot of the stuff that got shared
about him none of it was illegal stuff
yeah yeah you know and they just people
they're like oh what about this 22 year
old woman that he was communicating with
you're like
well that's there's nothing you know it
might be a sh
that's you know there's a difference
between being a dog of a man
and being a pervert or a criminal perv
would i have to say about him because i
didn't and i i
i don't want to get in trouble you know
that's the thing i i've been
pretty silent about you know talking
about
this yeah me too but i um want to say
one thing
which i'm trying to gather words is
that i do the allegations are shocking
but i do have to say that he's just
just personally one of the nicest
generous good guys
that i've ever met in in the business
you know he
he's him and his family have only been
even
you know when i was struggling stuff the
sweetest
people and he's he's only been
the sweetest guy you know um
and um i've not said that out loud
and because you know we live in a world
where you know
you know you get this fear that like am
i going to get cancelled too or
and what not but i i've been also
thinking about
why can't i say that yeah you know why
can't i say
you know that you know chris delia
is just one of the nicest guys i've ever
met
personally in my life you know i've
never seen him
do all the things that you know he's
been accused of doing
um i don't and i also i'm also you know
i'm
on the side of always victims you know i
feel you know if people have been
victimized
but that's not what i'm saying right now
all i'm saying is is that you know
that's the thing that i've been scared
to say because i don't want people to
think that i'm defending him
i'm not i'm just saying that you know
that's what i know of him that he's just
being a
a good guy yeah do you have this same
experience i mean chris has been super
nice to me i mean you know helpful with
work i don't you and i you and him are
closer
yeah because you all have more of a
history together yeah yeah you know
yeah uh but it's just so
uncomfortable to say that because it's
like you know um yeah and it shouldn't
be
but it all it like yeah it shouldn't
mean just because we talk about someone
that it means like we
don't like support somebody that if
somebody was taking advantage of it yeah
i i don't support the behavior right
that's uh the behavior if someone's
victimized
you know i mean i'm not i i'm on their
[ __ ] side
that's not what i'm talking about i'm
just saying that why can't i say to
you i mean that he is just my opinion
about him you know
it's like yeah totally yeah when people
are more than one thing
you know like people are like i said
before like people are
complex creatures right it's like when
people like
who's that guy huh he's not here live
but he is a human and
no i just i want to add one last thing
it's like
the same thing as i feel about carlos
mencia
right and what what he went through it's
like
you know i was his opening act when all
that [ __ ] went down wow really
yeah would you do did you speak up or do
you not no i [ __ ] cut ties and i
[ __ ] ran like a guy
wow do you feel bad about that now or no
you know there is parts of me that feel
bad but at the time right i wasn't you
know i was a guy
trying to make a name for myself yeah
it's so hard and it's like i was just
trying to
you know you know there's a parts of me
that are
kind of hate talking about [ __ ] like
this but there's parts of me that's
you know opportunistic i guess
you know i you know i had spent you know
how hard it is in the beginning
so i spent so much time like working on
this thing
and i just had this fear that i was
going to lose everything so
i could ties it from him and and i read
on the internet
all these things about him and it is
true did he steal jokes yeah
you know but does that make him evil
no agreed there's he's a good dad you
know
he he's a lot of things i would have i
would have never
made it without him he's done so many
generous things
for me and it's like would i say that
[ __ ] around
you know rogan or no i don't i keep you
know i we that [ __ ] doesn't even come up
because i know how certain people feel
about them you know i mean but
you know um people are complex creatures
you know and it's like
yeah we and and somehow like it seems a
lot of times like the media just can
say that this person is only one thing
and then we they're labeled as that and
then
and then that's the only thing that they
are and it's like it's just so
tacky like i think one thing scary it's
scary [ __ ] scary dude
it's scary true but it's also tacky
it's like in a time when we're supposed
to be like
recognizing that you know people have
depth and that people are not just
one thing they're not just the uh the
color of their skin or just their
behavior or just this cert
one thing yeah that everybody has a
redemptions you know like
it's just yeah also it's like movies
that i like
are redemption movies right people that
made mistakes
right and then they're able to at the
end of the movie right you know
make amends and and to change and to
learn
that's what life is about is to grow
and make mistakes fall learn right and
adjust or whatever
yeah right but in we live in a society
now is you make one mistake
or a series of mistakes you're out
forever you're done [ __ ] you and it's
crazy because we
all may we've all we are all oh my god i
made so many mistakes
so many made you know i know this is a
comedy
don't make them right but this is like
we i think just there's certain times
where we have to be real sometimes we
are yeah good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch
this one watch this one